well about a week ago
a school principal in new jersey sent an
email to parents at the school
apologizing for a photograph that
appeared in the school's
yearbook the picture was taken in
october
what was the picture well it wasn't of
the virginia governor the kids weren't
posing in blackface or wearing clan
robes no they were carrying an american
flag with a blue
stripe on it a blue lives matter flag it
honors police officers killed in the
line of duty the cops were at the school
for the dare program
which keeps kids off drugs most
wholesome scenario you can imagine
but the image horrified the principle of
the school william myron
he wrote that the picture was quote
understandably appalling and then he
continued with woke speak befitting a
corporate hr department
quote the need for growth is apparent i
wish we had realized in october any of
the negative associations with the
picture
we should have known i personally can
only apologize
that i did not some parents were
confused by this
one of them a father named brian
michelle responded this way
writing as a parent a millburn resident
and an american i found your letter to
be not only condescending and offensive
but also spurious misguided
and ironically intolerant of anyone
holding views
which do not conform to the currently
prescribed and carefully constructed
language
of wokeness that parent brian michelle
joins us tonight ryan thanks so much for
coming on
so i just want to be clear to the
audience sometimes you have guests on
and nobody knows the backstory you are
not a political activist you're not
apparently a very political person you
don't have
some complex political agenda you're
just a parent
with kids in the school and you were
confused by what the principal said
and i'll let you take it from there
yeah no tucker that's right and um you
know i actually wasn't really confused i
knew exactly what was happening
um yeah and you know i follow the news i
see what's happening with canceled
culture and i see what's happening to
anyone who speaks out
and dares to veer off of the uh
carefully constructed script
that you know businesses and politicians
are meant to
convey when they're speaking about these
things but what really seemed appalling
to me actually
much more so than a photograph of
football players holding an american
flag and a thin blue line flag
what was truly appalling was the fact
that it seemed that dr myron
myron was reacting without even thinking
about the kids
so he's calling the flag that these boys
are holding these football players he's
calling the flag racist
so essentially he's saying these boys
are out there waving a racist flag
around
without any regard to what that might
mean to
the boy's images or the boys futures now
to be branded
in such a way that clearly wasn't their
intention i was actually at that
football game that day and i remember
where they were honoring the dare
program and they came out and it was a
wonderful night
and so that's where some shock came in
it's like is that the night you're
talking about
uh there seemed to be a lots of town and
school unity that night
yeah um and and clearly at that time
nobody had an objection to
uh holding an american flag or a thin
blue line flag
so when i see that level of hypocrisy it
did
inspire me to write a letter i had no
intention of
it um uh going any far any further than
the you know the school board and
the principal and the superintendent but
when i was asked to come on and talk
about that
i felt it was my duty you know as a
father and as a citizen
to actually stand up and say uh what i'm
saying shouldn't be controversial
and it shouldn't be polarizing as as
polarizing as that
that email that we all received was um
i'm just talking about
um you know free speech and i'm talking
about the the idea that
we should not be so quick to
judge one another based on what the
current culture is telling us
is so every point you've made
is rooted in common sense and decency
and concern for other people and i bet
you 85
of americans would agree with every word
that just came out of your mouth and yet
you were taking a real risk coming on
this show
a risk to your livelihood to your family
we're not overstating that
and so i just really fervently hope you
were not punished
for saying what most people think in a
gentle and rational way i really really
do
brian so our our thoughts are with you
tonight thank you for standing up and
saying that
thank you tucker i appreciate it